the Joe Rogan experience do you watch
many fights outside of although yeah
they every day outside of MMA yeah yeah
like jiu-jitsu or more time or I watch
all uh in jiu-jitsu in it when it's
really getting going you know I was
gonna try and come out here a day before
and try SeaWorld's you know it depends
but yeah I try yeah it's um it's
interesting when you see how good people
are at those individual disciplines you
know that's uh it's one of the more
interesting aspects about MMA is that
you really can't be the best in the
world at everything and you're gonna
have because it's such a complex reward
you certainly can but you right though I
think a lot of a lot of these other
sports and stuff they've had so many
years just to figure out what works and
what don't work that they've really
refined the the process you know what I
mean yeah like you see some of these
high high level boxers and it's like
they've had you know you talk about
somebody like Floyd he said his dad
fight and his uncle fight before him to
where he's like refined the the process
so much there it's damn near perfect you
know I mean we haven't got to that point
yet never man know it's gonna be awhile
no clothes not even I don't know if
we'll ever get there because it seems
like it's because it's a combination of
so many different disciplines it's you
just it doesn't seem like you're ever
gonna see the a guy who is world-class
Muay Thai and world-class jujitsu and
world-class wrestling all in one fighter
it just doesn't seem like that's really
possible I think you can get it in a
couple more generations don't think so
it may be like four more generations
some like that like because this is it
like I look at the kids now that are
coming up and they don't have the same
like preconceptions that that even I had
coming up in it you know like where when
if you boxing your boxing this way and
you know this is the right thing to do
this is the wrong thing to do you know
or you taken you've taken so many things
and you're not really you're kind of
stuck on it you know what I mean and I
feel like
each generation is getting a little bit
better a little bit better I look at
like some of the things that kids do now
I'm like [ __ ] like I want to like wish I
could it could be that free and just
kind of have that that creative process
to do it you know it's gonna happen
eventually I think yeah with little kids
are starting off like a little amateur
fights with more like 10 years old yeah
so then I think about his kid you know
and what's it gonna look like and then
okay and then what's his kid gonna look
like to where you will get somebody who
is who is just perfect whatever they do
that's a good point because it really is
a big factor that Floyd had his dad who
was a world-class fighter Sugar Ray
Leonard and his uncle Roger was the
black mamba Roger Mayweather was the
[ __ ] man back in the eighties you
know to see those two guys training him
that is gigantic grown up in that
environment
always been around boxing and they could
tell them what to do and what not to do
even when you get to that certain level
you know it's like it's you don't know
what you don't know until it's too late
oh but you know he had people that he
really respected like his I mean you
your uncle in you and your pops they're
gonna be the first people that you
respect and you got it listen to him
yeah so I think it played a huge factor
that people don't really look at it I
think so too and that's also seeing
their mistakes that other fighters have
made when you're growing up in the gym
you seen guys that's spar too hard or
seeing guys that get hit too much or
seeing guys that take the wrong fight so
thin guys don't fight smart defensively
you know one of the things that people
forget is that Floyd went through a big
transition of his own if you go back to
the early parts of his career and you
watch when he was pretty boy floyd yeah
he was a much more aggressive fighter
and he would put himself in danger much
more and then when he became money
Mayweather like as got later and later
in his life he just got so much more
brilliant defensively and then he became
the guy that you see shutting out Canelo
Alvarez stopping all these guys just
just shutting everything down he just
became this defensive wizard to the
point where you'd see world-class
fighters like Sugar Shane Mosley who did
tag him but other than that didn't
really know once he once he recovered he
don't really know what to do with Floyd
boy just had the answers to his style he
had figured him out
yeah and I even see a lot of people uh
because I go by his gym from time to
time you know it's and I see like a lot
of people that are coming up in boxing
who just wanna right out the gate be
what Floyd is now you know I mean be on
the ropes and and be able to slip
punches and you know and but they forget
like the time when he beat the [ __ ] out
of our tour Gotti right you know today
you know it was no defense to it he just
came out was throwing hands like they
forget all the like amateur fights that
he had before that that he's won and
loss and you know he just had a
different style of fighting so it's it
takes time to get to that that that
level you know I mean certainly Toro
gotta fight was brutal brutal yeah yeah
he's a monster I give him a lot of
respect I do you know I mean not a lot
of people do but they're crazy the man's
just being him well he talks a lot of
[ __ ] but you got to separate that from
what he does yeah I mean when you watch
him fight the guy is defensively
spectacular yeah he knows exactly when
you watch the Canela fight I've watched
eikenella fight at least three times and
when you watch him stand in front of
Canelo Canela throws a left he's over
he's right
he's over here pop take that jab with
you yeah oh and I'm back and Janelle is
like just with him yeah who's throwing
punches you could see that the look in
his face like god dammit I'm in here
with a master yeah this is a master
boxer and I'm learning a lesson here
[Applause]